let's bring in our financial gurus to
dispense some advice here Steve Forbes
chairman to editor-in-chief of Forbes
media and Chris Hogan radio talk-show
host author and personal finance expert
Chris you've been listening to these
stories tonight from our business owners
New Jersey Massachusetts in Vermont
right you know we're kind of focused in
that part of the country for no good
reason but just you know those are
places that are still subject to these
pretty draconian lockdown orders what do
you do when you're in a situation like
this is it is it civil disobedience is
it lawsuits or you know just pray at
this point well Laura what you see with
all three of these business owners are
people that are fighting to survive
these business owners are very serious
about their business these aren't
hobbies this is how they're serving
their customers this is how they're
providing for their families and so they
need the opportunity to be able to push
forward and the road to recovery doesn't
happen sitting and hiding it's about us
moving forward clearly and being aware
taken precautions as the gentleman said
up north they're doing everything they
can to keep people safe when they come
in we need that right to be able to move
forward in this country Steve Forbes you
got the sense today from the president
that he's just about done with these
draconian lockdown orders he sees the
real hunger and the American people to
get back to work safely
I love Frank's story the immigrant story
hard-worker reminds me of my mom stories
about her parents and just that ethic of
I want to get out there and work I don't
want to sit at home and watch some
Netflix and wait for a check I want to
be out there working and that's the
story of America and what about all
these immigrant businesses now where do
they go Steve unless we start giving
people confidence to get back in well
that's why the pressure whether it's
civil disobedience of how now going
after your representatives and the like
petitioning has got to be done we
already know we've seen it in Florida
we've seen it in Georgia Colorado which
has a Democrat governor but he used to
do businesses before he knows no revenue
you don't survive so we got to keep this
opening going with deliberate speed we
know we can be done safely we've seen it
in action
practice and the other two things by
what by the way the federal government
can do is provide liability protection
when these businesses open they don't
get harassed by lawsuits frivolous
lawsuits the other thing they can do is
suspend the payroll tax so when you hire
somebody you pay them you know at the
cost of labor is less they earn more
win-win all around
and one other thing Laura that I'm
surprised that the federal government
hasn't done is the Treasury Department's
kept on the reason ridiculous
restrictions on getting loans from the
PPP program like 75% of your money has
to go for payroll the fact the matter is
for a lot of businesses utilities rent
are the biggest expenses Treasury can
throw out those dumb rules right now I
don't know why they don't do it so all
of the above you pray you you fight you
get out there and you pressure and do
the demonstrations work the New Jersey
wouldn't have gone as far as it did
which is almost nowhere if people hadn't
gone out and don't started to do these
demonstrations we've seen in other parts
of the country - yeah and our business
owners guys have some specific questions
for economic money gurus so I'm going to
open it up now Nick let's go to you
first Nick what's your question so allow
business owners have IRA or 401 k's and
we are not getting the funding that we
should get this is supposed to be eight
weeks long and the PPP money's supposed
to last for eight weeks now we're on
what ten weeks longer maybe two months
three months if we pull from a horrible
case or IRS
what kind of penalties are going to be
waived if they're gonna be waived and
then are gonna be tax exempt possibly
for that Chris what should we handle
that yes well with the cares Act what
they did was they lifted the 10% penalty
on that but you're still going to be
liable for the taxes over a two year
period so pulling money out of there
right now there's nothing in place to
shield you at all you would still have
to pay the taxes on it over a two year
period of time and so guys I know as you
look at your business and you're
thinking okay we are ready to open we're
trying to do whatever's necessary I just
want to caution you as you do that
essentially you're pulling from the
future to take care of the present so
you
to be really mindful I tell people there
are two reasons to touch retirement
funds that's to prevent a foreclosure or
to prevent a personal bankruptcy so be
really mindful of that as you walk this
path let's go to Frank now Frank of
course on the restaurant business Frank
you have a question about capacity I
want to know if the how I'm supposed to
pay a hundred percent of my bills but
only 25% of the occupancy that the that
the government is telling me that I'm
supposed to do with six B separation
well first of all we know it's a three
feet is good rather than six feet and
second this micromanaging nitpicking 25
percent thirty two point three percent
is ridiculous they're arbitrary numbers
it should be what you can safely do and
you make the judgment and let people
judge if they think a place is safe and
unsafe we now know we the elderly are
more vulnerable if you have certain
conditions you're more vulnerable trust
the people the information is out there
you post the information you provide the
mast although I'm sure you're finding
ways to allow us to eat and have the
mask nearby but they these arbitrary
numbers are just nonsense
they should be gotten rid of use your
judgment and the people will make the
decision is this safe or unsafe you've
got to have revenue now I think the idea
of measuring feet and then I saw
something yesterday guys what it's
really 18 feet I kid you not there was a
video on one of our cable competitors
like well it's really 18 feet I mean
next week it'll be a mile then you can
still get covered all right II W hold on
hold on Chris we got to get he W inch
and he's not gonna get his question II
WI want to make sure you speak up
because your little Skype was a little
low last time so II W you have a
question go ahead my friend sure know if
states are required to provide
compensation for the taking or effective
taking of a business or property through
regulation for the benefit of everyone
else in this case Public Safety is what
we've been told why is that not
happening well go to yeah who wants to
take that of the gurus I asked Chris you
take it
well I don't know to be honest with you
I think right now what you have on the
government side is there's a lot of
China of trying to figure it this out on
the move you got to remember this is
brand-new aw we've never seen anything
like this from a pandemic situation we
have seen situations where we've had
tough times 911 y2k the Great Recession
of oh seven and oh nine so these states
all these governors remember are
operating autonomously they can make
some decisions and so I don't know I
think I would find you I'm putting
pressure on my state reps I'm going to
go have meetings to find out what are
they doing to help right now what
they've done is given you a lot of
restrictions and prevented you from
providing for your family
hi gentlemen I'm gonna just let me just
jump in there because I will say this I
will say this hold on I will say this
creative lawyers can come up with good
causes of action and you're on the right
track aw with talking about a takings if
you're taking people's livelihood
you must compensate them on the other
side and I think you're thinking the
right way all you CEOs small businesses
medium-size get together and put
pressure legislatively through lawsuits
and so forth and you're gonna be in good
stead all of you great to see you keep
up the good fight and